foreign
very cool man thanks for calling brother
what's up
so uh I'm 19. I'm in college and I grew
up homeschooled so I wasn't allowed to
date until the age of 18. last summer I
went to summer camp with one of my
friends and met a girl and we hit it off
pretty well she was in a relationship at
the time summer no I didn't
so so I didn't you know I didn't push
anything we were just friends and then a
couple weeks later she was not going to
sitting out of the Tulsa so we didn't
get to see each other very often
a couple weeks later her boyfriend broke
up with her because he said that's what
God wanted for them and so I kind of got
soft rebounded on that um she kind of I
touched on to me and then I thought this
was the beginning of a relationship
and then she just kept kind of being
I don't think she meant any harm by it
but she kept being a little more
lovey-dovey than I was used to from a
girl
she said it's just because she's
Southern and that's how she rolls and
then wait wait wait what does
lovey-dovey mean
like saying I love you every night and
saying you're handsome and saying she
want to be my roommate when we get out
of college and stuff like that
okay
I mean
having never gone any farther than the
talking phase with anybody before that
was a lot more than I was used to and I
was excited about it of course hey hold
on let's stop right there it feels good
when somebody tells you that you're good
looking
yeah
it feels good when someone says like I I
see a future with you yeah so it feels
awesome man so don't don't you're not
weird that's incredible feels good it
might be it might be a wrong person it
might be dumb but it's not yeah your
feelings are valid man right right those
words definitely have positive impact
and I appreciate that but
I don't know if she fully meant them the
way she said them
um so there's a sheep hold on hold on
hold on hold on if you can learn what
I'm about to say at the age of 19 I'm
gonna change your life forever
okay
there's a psychological construct called
the fundamental attribution error okay
and here's what that means fundamental
attribution error I'm gonna I'm gonna
way oversimplify it but essentially it's
I'm getting inside somebody else's head
in deciding why they did what they did
and said what they said
and what I want to tell you is that is a
complete and utter waste of your entire
life because you'll never know we do it
with politicians he just did that
politicians he just did that because of
this or we do it with our parents
they're just trying to our coaches and
here's the deal we have no idea we have
no idea right and so it's a waste of
time I'm gonna judge somebody on what
they said I'm gonna judge somebody on
what they do and I'm going to judge
myself on both my feelings and the next
right move right and so I'm just gonna
I'm just gonna leave things at face
value if people don't tell me the truth
then I'm gonna respond to that I'm not
going to get in their head and try to
figure out why are they lying it's just
an exhausting way to live
right don't attribute to malice what you
contribute to ignorance or don't
attribute anything ever
don't attribute anything that also works
too yeah total I mean the number of
times dude I've walked home and I've
been married for I've been married
longer than you've been alive or that
I've walked into my house and there's
shoes laying around or there's something
there and I just instantly create a
story as to why those are there right I
have no idea what my wife's been through
during the day none and by the way
they're my stupid shoes she also created
a story about why I left my crap out
right so it's just it's it's
our whole culture is based on making up
false stories and shoving them into
other people's minds and then blaming
them for them and then judging them for
them and then going to war on social
media or in the news forum absolute
Insanity absolute waste of time
okay that helped
um anyway so she was I found out she was
hanging out with other guys apparently
sometimes she does a lot she hangs out
one with other guys and then starts
complaining when they get like the wrong
vibes from her because she's too
emotionally attaching and stuff
um so we've been I got soft friend zoned
by her probably around like Christmas
time and then the last time we hung out
um I didn't really feel a connection
anymore
okay so I've been pulling back a little
bit and it feels a lot I feel like
looking back now I see how I was
not making the best decisions at the
time and reading too much into motives
and stuff hold on don't do that to
yourself
this is your first go round
yeah you're just you're just learning
yeah and somebody told you they loved
you somebody told you that you were real
handsome somebody said hey I see myself
with you in the future I felt awesome
and then you realized oh she told a
whole bunch of other people that too
yeah here's the here's the word you're
trying to intellectualize this as a like
as a first go around
I want you just to sit in the the grief
of it all
she didn't tell you the truth man it
hurts yeah
she kind of LED you on that hurts
to prevent repeating that so I move past
her we don't talk much anymore
um she's with another guy and they seem
to be happy and happy for them I have
forgiven her to the extent that I can
right now there's still a little scar
going on but it's given me trust issues
yeah of course like yeah like
when someone says they're like so this
girl I'm interested right now uh met her
a week ago we've been friends on social
media for a couple months
I I don't know like I don't want to read
anything into what she's doing now
because of what happened don't read
anything into anybody ever right exactly
exactly to ask questions and get
information right yeah just get to hey
get to know people you're not
downloading you're not downloading
software
right you're interacting with people and
here's another thing you can have
um
you can have great
super fun relationships with people
that aren't romantic yeah and when you
meet somebody who makes you laugh you
meet somebody that you think is pretty
you meet somebody that as brilliant is a
good thinker
um
like
you don't have to instantly start
putting them in a spreadsheet and trying
to classify what what what column they
go in yeah they're just a great person
that you just met this is awesome Yep
and then you hang on to your values
whatever your values are
I only hold hands and kiss and go on
dates with people that I am pursuing a
long-term romantic relationship if
that's the value you want to set for
yourself knock your lights out or I want
to date a whole bunch of people and
experience a whole bunch of people and
have all kinds of Adventures and great
hang on to those values that's separate
and apart from man I really like
spending time with her she's awesome
she's hilarious she's fun
yep
um and that doesn't mean that I have to
like is she romantic and what she's
trying to say I don't know how she's
trying to say it you start to read voice
tone into text messages and instagramers
like DMS right like okay
a little bit you do it all the time
Andrew all the time every day yeah every
day so
um here's what I want you to do I want
you to imagine on the top of your head
and I'm being I'm I'm gonna sound like
I'm making a joke I'm not being totally
serious okay every time you start
finding yourself okay what is it what
does this mean what is she saying
I want you to imagine there's a pressure
release valve on top of your head like a
like a like a like a hose faucet that
goes on the side of your house and I
want you to reach your hand up do this
in private otherwise someone's gonna
institutionalize you do it in private
and I want you just to pretend that
you're turning it and make the noise
let the pressure off
if you don't feel like responding that
day don't respond anytime you think I
have to respond to this person I have to
go do this thing
that's what I want you to challenge
because you're just creating pressure
where pressure does not exist if you
feel like you want to cool and
um I dated people I dated a few people
seriously before I got married I am
somebody that likes to talk all the time
too much
yeah and then I was dating somebody who
didn't like talking and so I started not
talking trying to preserve this thing
all right
then I realized this is never gonna work
because I'm somebody who talks a lot
my wife doesn't love it but she puts up
with it because she loves me you see
what I'm saying right yeah yeah that
makes sense don't lose in in your new
found like I am dating now I am out in
the world I am meeting people I'm do
don't
don't over professionalize it
practice being with other people
practice experiencing here's who I want
to be in this moment and if this person
doesn't like who I am in this moment if
I'm being a jerk I need to learn
something if I talk too much and I'm
kind of annoying I need to learn some
things
or this person is making me feel
different than I want to feel or this
person is I I want to do things
so that they think I'm a certain way or
they see me in a certain light I'm
telling you there's an expiration date
on that
that eventually Runs Out
because eventually the real you
it has to breathe and that's when that
person can rightfully go hey you've not
been telling me the truth either that's
not who you are you're a funny silly guy
or you're a very serious guy are you
somebody who meets somebody and wants to
get serious really fast great there will
be somebody out there for you may not be
this person somebody will meet you and
want to get serious real quick too
awesome knock your lights out
don't compromise your values and don't
overthink this the pressure valve on top
of your head just turn it
here dude you're in the right place
Andrew in the right place keep this keep
this in mind practice you're just
practicing you're learning new skills my
brother